δεν είχε να κείνον το εξάιτμε το οποίο εγώ ήθελα στη ζωημο επίσεις δεν ήταν
το καλύτερο μου να έχω να κάμουμε με παιδιάς το σχολείων διότι και εγώ ύμον
έναν από αυτά τα παιδιά και έβλεπα το πως μας έβλεπαν όπως πως έβλεπαν πως
βλέπο εμείς τους καθηγητές δε ήθερα και εγώ να είναι ένας από υτούς καλώς μάθεη
της αντρέας τοσχολείο η ακολούθο στα φιρητικά του χρόνια αντίθετα ημού πολύ καλός μας ετεί
το σχολείο στα φιρητικά χρόνια νομίζω κινδύνεψα είχα υποτροφία ην δευσατη χάσω την υποτροφία διό
ότι δεν ήπουν καθόλου καλώς αφιτητής η πρωτερεότητα μου όταν επία λονδίνον δεν ήταν να
είναι καλώς στο πανεπιστήμιο ήταν περνά ο καλά για πρώτη φορά που έμενα μόνοσμου πως
όλι φιρητές μόλις φύγο ποναι κάποιο περισσότερο από κάποιους άλλους εγώ ναι νομίζω ότι έπρεπε
να φτάσω στο σιβίο να στείλει επιστολήν το πρί της χάνσι στους γονίσμου να τους
πει ότι ο αντρέας θα χάσει την υποτροφία και θα πρέπει να πληρώσετε τα λεφτά
που σας δώσαμε σηγύραμιλάμε και για ένα μεγάλον μποσοήταν μεγάλον τοποσό και εκεί ήταν ένας
πάτσος ο οποίος έπρεπε να έρθει για να θέρω τα μήλιαμο βουλεμε και να επανέλθω
στο σ στο δρόμο του αρχίσω να μελετόκαι το δύο χιγιες α δεν κάνω λάθως
κάποδιαμαζα εξαπό μια αντράπεζα ο αντρέας βάζει κάποιες ειδές το μυαλόν του και παίνει μέσα
σε αυτή και τη ησυλοποι ναι σχεδόν βασιάοι τράπες δα ήσε στο πανεπιστήμιο εγώ ήμου
στη φάση όπου τελεί να τοπί εστίγμου και πρέπεδώ για πρώτη φορά καις επαγγελματικές επιλογές
ήθελαν ακολουθεήσω δεν ήξερα καν τι σημαίνει επεδητική τράπεζα ήρθαν στο μανεπιστήμιο κάποιες τράπεζες γιατί
γύρευαν άτοματα ο οποία τελείο να εντοπίο ιστή τους ήθελα